[Music]
what's this
it's a journal so you can write to your
son
what do i write
tell them who you are
what you believe in
and tell them you love them
[Music]
dear jordan
the moment i met your mother i knew she
was the one he is not exactly my title
[Music]
after some convincing she fell for me
too
i think you are beautiful
[Music]
i want to see more of your city
i want to see more of your city i'll
take your state your zip code
[Music]
real love takes sacrifice
[Music]
we can make this work
[Music]
then you came into our lives
and you were a blessing
how come you barely ever talk about him
i think about him all the time
always be courageous in everything you
do
but never be afraid to cry
wow
[Music]
i
will
try i pray i don't run out of
time love you to fix you
i was just thinking that if you need sex
just to help you get through it
then i don't want another woman and i
hope you don't expect me to extend that
same offer because you better keep that
locked up
exclusively in movie theaters this
christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you